ils encourent les vieilles pierres de la
commanderie des templiers ont des choses
à nous raconter
il visite découverte entre patrimoine et
art contemporain nous est proposé le
premier dimanche de chaque mois dans le
cadre du label ville d'art et d'histoire
il ya la moitié de la vie qui est
vraiment sur l'histoire et
l'architecturé des lieux
et puis dans le même temps on propose
aux gens de découvrir l'exposition
actuelle du site donc l'exposition d'art
contemporain puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est le
coeur du projet de la commanderie des
templiers
donc en ce moment c'est une exposition
de dessins ça change régulièrement et
comme ça les gens forment même revenir
plusieurs fois avec leurs amis et le
voir une exposition différente à chaque
fois sur les chemins de saint jacques de
compostelle
ce lieu emblématique fondée au 12e
siècle par les moines soldats de l'ordre
du temple a connu de multiples
affectations utilisé au départ pour
l'accueil des pèlerins qui convertit en
exploitation agricole
la commanderie est restaurée est ouverte
au public dans les années 70 une
deuxième vague de restauration 2008 et
en fait aujourd'hui un centre culturel
et historique à vocation polyvalente
l'art contemporain est à l'honneur cette
année dans le bâtiment des garde qui
accueille les expositions temporaires
l'originalité de la visite à deux voix
offre ainsi au public une mise en
parallèle entre l'histoire de ce lieu de
patrimoine et l'art contemporain qui est
exposée on n'avait jamais eu de parcours
historique sur la commanderie on a
l'habitude de voir des sculptures
modernes ici des artistes des artistes
contemporains ils sont nous choque pas
de le mélange des deux
la chapelle derniers témoins médiévale
de la région et les expositions sont à
découvrir tous les premiers dimanches du
mois